hello there and here again first of all
we have a guest today we have my friend
gabrielle from brazil
visiting and who also has his own uh
facebook page yes and a youtube channel
we have we have everything the website
as well but the facebook the facebook
page i'm especially proud of and you
speak how many languages i would say i
can have a
decent conversation in 10.
so
gabriel can i have taken the questions
that i received here on my channel and i
kind of summarized them a bit i wrote it
out in my handwriting i don't know if
gabriel can read my own writing
he's going to ask me the question i'll
give an answer he may disagree or
whatever and we'll see how it goes oh it
sounds great okay i'm excited about this
so the first uh
the first two questions are a bit uh
related okay the first one is
uh in swedish right how how do you learn
uh the different forms of of the words
in swedish because there's different
declansions right i personally don't
have a lot of knowledge of swedish but
um
and the second one is how do you
basically learn a
verb conjugations for example
right
and of course even me as a native
speaker have problems with conjugating
words in portuguese sometimes so how do
how do you do that steve
well you know it's a problem in a number
of languages i mean there are a number
of languages where the nouns or the
adjectives change you know declensions
and verbs change per person
you know tense or whatever
and i
have gone through the experience of
trying to study the tables and i find
that it's not very helpful
i still review them
because i come across different forms of
a noun or a verb and i'm not entirely
sure what the
form what form that is and then i'll
google for that noun or that verb and
i'll see the table and so i
go back there all regular it's like
going to the water cooler in an office
you go there for a glass of water you
come back the main thing is you just
have to get used to them like the person
asked a question about swedish and said
there's so many different forms of
plurals i i don't even know that
like i don't even know that but i speak
swedish actually quite well it's one of
my better languages because i've spoken
in a lot i've listened to a lot of audio
books on swedish history and stuff but
so
i think what i do is when i'm reading
for example for portuguese yeah vera and
veer is it's kind of confusing
every time i see it i try to if i'm
reading a book i'll underline it if i'm
on link i'll save that phrase i want to
help my brain notice whenever that
occurs whenever that appears
but it's just a matter of a lot of of
exposure and there are no quick
solutions coupled with occasionally
reviewing the tables but to try to nail
down like the person asked
when i come across a noun in swedish
should i remember all the forms you
can't remember all the forms it's not
even worth trying you won't so that
would be my answer there yeah islamic
language is the same like russian
there's
all the cases and you have to know that
it's uh it's intense
so the question the third question here
finding how do you find the the time
steve to i'm i'm guessing either
learning or keeping up learning or
keeping up i mean the big thing is is
his listing you know i i would say that
70 80 of my learning time is listening
so if i'm doing anything around the
house i'm listening if i'm in the car
i'm listening if i'm uh cleaning the
garage i'm listening you know exercising
i'm listening so the listening enables
you to get up to that sort of critical
mass one hour minimum a day and then if
i listen to something i don't understand
it then i gotta read then i gotta link
it right then i'll perhaps work on my
ipad i do a lot of work i should say now
on my ipad using ilink
because it's very handy i sit down in a
you know a comfortable chair i'm
sometimes on my stepper at home so
it's a matter of trying to find ways to
use you know dead time during the day
man something i think i think that this
is this is really cool uh personally i
really like alternating into active and
passive listening so sometimes i'm just
driving i'm driving around right and i
have a language
so i'm just content whatever it is and
uh and then sometimes if i if i have
time and i can focus on the language
then i go for active listening then i'm
really paying attention and maybe
reading the content as well maybe only
maybe on something else right right
yeah i mean i ten
i tend not to do i mean it depends on
your definition of active listening i
won't sit down and listen i can never do
that if i sit down to learn i'm going to
read read or link
but on the other hand most of the things
i listen to
unless i'm very advanced in the language
i'm also going to read
so in russian today i don't have to read
it i'll understand most of it but in my
polish for example everything that i'm
listening to i've read i've linked and
then i listened so however i don't just
sit down and listen i never do that but
everyone does their own you
know question number four what is
fluency
you know you get this question all the
time to me it doesn't matter
uh i've done business with people who
speak english whose native
language is not english who make
mistakes and they communicate and i'm
sure that when i communicate in other
languages i make mistakes so if you can
communicate you're good like i we can
always improve
and yet i'm always glad
that i'm able to do whatever i'm able to
do
fluency i mean i guess the definition is
simply a fluency is that that you are
comfortable
handling you understand what people are
saying and you can communicate on a
variety of subjects
even though your pronunciation may not
be all that great and you make mistakes
and you're sometimes at a loss for words
and sometimes you don't understand what
they're saying but by and large you're
communicating and the person isn't
making allowances for you
you know
so that that's what it is i personally i
agree and i also agree that i mean it's
not a lot of people put a lot of
emphasis in it